Next up-- the war on Santa.
If you're watching this show
with your kids,
you're a great parent!
Thank you!
And, also, sorry for all
the times I did this. Aah!
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
But...
before this next piece,
here is a disclaimer.
MAN:
Spoiler alert.
AUKERMAN:
This is dance.
According to a new study,
it's damaging
for parents
to lie to kids about Santa Claus
before Jesus' birthday.
Here's a fair and balanced take
from Fox News.
MAN: They suggest
that lying to children
could undermine their trust
in parents,
as a result leaving them open
to abject disappointment.
If parents can lie
so convincingly
and over such a long time,
what else can they lie about?
-Yeah.
-(laughter)
First of all, (bleep) you,
(bleep) those kids.
This is all dumb.
Yeah, I love this.
Like, oh, don't lie
to your kids, but go ahead
and keep getting your news from
a totally biased news source.
-(cheers and applause)
-Oh! -Wow!
Nope. Nope. I'm out.
-I'm out.
-HARDWICK: You're in. You're in.
-Scott's out?
-Aukerman out.
-Aukerman's in.
-CARVEY: You know, uh...
(imitating Trump):
This wasn't very nice, okay?
You're not very nice, okay?
When's this on? Midnight?
-Why? Why? -HARDWICK: I don't
know. -What a nasty man.
-What a nasty man. -It's not
even on at midnight.
Comedians, at this very
sensitive time of year,
what else is triggering you
about Santa Claus?
-Scott Aukerman.
-Now I don't believe it
when I hear
anyone who's coming to down.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
My uncle, Cavalia.
HARDWICK:
Yeah, none of 'em.
-The I Loved The 90s Tour.
-HARDWICK: Points.
-Chelsey Crisp.
-I saw Mommy kissing him,
but he didn't have a beard,
and he looked a lot
-like her Pilates instructor?
-All right, points.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-He was ripped!
-He was just ripped. Santa was
jacked. -Just (bleep) ripped.
-Dana. -I'm a vegan, but I eat
reindeer meat out of spite.
HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
Very good, very good.
-(laughter, applause)
-You'll show them!